manu y sus diez compañeros pertenecen a
la cruz roja de andalucía viajan a ceuta
desde algeciras para aliviar a sus
colegas que hace cuatro días hacen
frente a la crisis migratoria que afecta
esta ciudad española ubicada en el norte
de áfrica hoy por la mañana no activaron
ayer a la laguna ya estamos
movilizándonos para poder para poder
actuar desde ayer por la noche aquí
vamos amplia y ya estamos para llegar
por eso a toda la persona que lo
necesite la cruz roja es casi la única
organización no gubernamental que ha
estado las 24 horas del día dando
socorro a los más de 8 mil migrantes que
cruzaron desde marruecos a españa días
algunos llegaban de noche pues llegaban
mojado y tenían hipotermia otro si
llegaban de día y habían estado mucho
rato en el mar el sol lo que venían era
deshidratado
manu si dirigió un improvisado centro de
acogida instalado en un polígono
industrial administrado por la policía
allí en ubicado a los menores donde
comida
ropa kit de higiene
intenta facilitar la estancia aquí
durante los días que vienen
el centro está vedado a la prensa
después de tres días en la calle dos
chicos de 15 y 16 años han decidido
voluntariamente entrar al recinto
hemos dormido en la calle en el campus y
también en una casa abandonada vinimos
aquí a buscar agua y comida
no podemos seguir abandonados a nuestra
suerte en la calle la cruz roja calcula
en 400 los menores de los que se está
haciendo cargo aquí en ceuta por su
parte el ministro del interior español
reconoció que 6500 personas entre
adultos y menores ya han regresado a
marruecos por lo tanto son todavía cerca
de 1000 los migrantes que deambulan por
la ciudad viviendo de la solidaridad
local durmiendo en la calle pero sobre
todo que continúan soñando con cruzar a
europa